[Music]
is there any way we can increase our
chances for a long and healthy life dr.
Joel Wallach explains why most chronic
and degenerative diseases are
preventable
through proper nutrition you'll learn
why people in certain cultures
throughout our world typically live well
over 120 years with almost no incidence
of cancer heart disease diabetes or
other common illnesses that shorten
human life you'll also learn the vital
role that minerals play in maintaining
our health and why our modern diets are
sorely lacking in these life-sustaining
nutrients listen now to a live
presentation by a man who is making a
major impact in the field of alternative
medicine dr. Joel Wallach well I'm
certainly glad you're here how many of
you grew up on a farm or still work a
farm or have anything do livestock well
I'll tell you what you're my kind of
people because I grew up on a farm in
West st. Louis County and we start out
with beef calves and if you raise
livestock the only way to make money is
if you raise a lot of your own feed for
those of you don't have that experience
and so we raised our own corn and we
raised our own soybeans in our own hay
and we had a truck come out from the
mill and this truck would come out from
the mill and it would grind up the corn
and the soybeans and the hay and then we
would add sacks of vitamins minerals
trace minerals and we make pellets out
of it and this is what we would feed the
calves in six months time we'd ship them
to market to be slaughtered we'd save
back some of the best ones for herself
we'd knock him in the head kneed him put
it bluntly and it always fascinated me
as a teenager that we did that for those
calves and in six months ship them off
to be slaughtered or we'd eat them and
we wanted to live to be a hundred years
of age without any aches and pains and
guess what we didn't take any vitamins
or minerals and that bothered me so I
asked my dad I'd say hey pops how come
you do that for those calves you don't
do that for us and he'd give me this
good old Missouri farm wisdom he'd say
things like shut up boy you're getting
this farm fresh food and we hope you
appreciate it
and course I was very quiet then because
I didn't want to miss out on any meals
well then when I went to school I went
to the University of Missouri School of
Agriculture and I got my degree in
agriculture I got my major and animal
husbandry in nutrition my minor was in
field crops and soils then I got into
veterinary school as a freshman
veterinary student I've learned to
answer to my question and the answer is
this we know how to prevent and cure
diseases and animals with nutrition and
the reason why we do that is because we
don't have major medical
we don't have hospitalization BlueCross
BlueShield we don't have Medicare if
you're gonna make money as a farmer you
better know how to do stuff yourself and
you better do it efficiently with feed
and nutrition if you can to make a long
story short after I got out of
veterinary school I went to Africa for
two years and I was able to fulfill a
boyhood dream I was able to be a Frank
buck for two years and worked with
Marlin Perkins many of you will remember
him from the mutual of Omaha's Wild
Kingdom and he's a great gentleman and
after two years of working with
elephants and rhinos people used to ask
me or are you a small animal vet or a
large animal vet while I was telling my
man extra large animal vet as I worked
with elephants and rhinos well after two
years he sent me a telegram and said
would you come back to the st. Louis Zoo
and work with us we need a wildlife
veterinarian at the zoo for a special
project we were given a seven and a half
million dollar grant from the National
Institutes of Health and what we need is
a veterinarian who'll do autopsies of
animals that died of natural causes in
the zoo well I was just overjoyed to do
that and so I came back and and of
course I not only did autopsies for
animals that died in the st. Louis Zoo
but the Brookfield Zoo in Chicago the
Bronx Zoo in New York the National Zoo
the LA Zoo and so forth and my job again
was to do autopsies of animals that died
of natural causes in the zoo and look
for a species of animals it was ultra
sensitive to pollution this because
during the early 60s we had just learned
about pollution and ecological problems
and disasters and nobody quite knew what
to do and so I was supposed to find a
species of animals it was extra
sensitive and used them much like we did
the Canaries in the mine you're the old
Welsh coal miners used to put a canary
in a little wicker cage and take it down
in the mine
if methane gas or carbon monoxide would
leak into the mine the canary would drop
off the perch and die first and the men
knew to get out before the mine blew up
are they suffocated again to make a long
story short over a period of some 12
years I did 17,500 autopsies on over 454
species of animals and 3,000 human
beings who lived in close proximity to
zoos and the thing that I found out was
this every animal and human being who
dies of natural causes dies of a
nutritional deficiency and that
fascinated me went back took me back to
those calves I said gee that's
fascinating we could document this at
autopsy
both chemically and biochemically and
things you saw with the eye at the
autopsy table
well that's fascinated me I wrote
scientific articles I wrote eight
multi-author textbooks in one textbook
of my own cause 140 bucks for medical
students and I'm sure the only thing
they do is use them for doorstops
and it couldn't get anybody excited I
was on 20/20 I was on 1,700 newspapers I
was in magazines it was in every network
TV that you can think of and guess what
couldn't get anybody excited back in the
60s about nutrition so what I did was
went back to school and became a
physician to use everything I'd learned
in veterinary school about nutrition of
my human patients and to no surprise to
me it worked
spent 12 years up in Portland Oregon and
general practice and it's very
fascinating what I'm going to share with
you tonight is what I learned over those
1012 years using nutrition with my human
patients and if you take home only 10%
it will save you an enormous amount of
unnecessary misery it will save you a
gob of money and those of you in
Missouri know what that means a gob
means a lot okay it'll add many
healthful years to your life well you
can't do this
you can't get these healthful years you
can't have longevity you can't live to
your genetic potential just falling off
a stump you have to do some things and
the first thing I have to do is convince
you that it is worth doing these things
I'm going to start out by convincing you
that the genetic potential for human
beings
is 120 years our genetic potential for
longevity in May 11th the oldest living
American at this time and documented
through the Guinness World Book of
Records was Margaret's keep she was from
Radford Virginia she died at age 115 and
she died of a nutritional deficiency you
can tell that from her obituary as she
died at the complications of a fall what
did she die from osteoporosis very good
she died of a calcium deficiency she had
no heart disease no cancer no diabeetus
no other infirmities but she died three
weeks after a fall because she didn't
have enough calcium her daughter said
that she had a craving for sweets until
she died and that's a disease called
pica we'll talk about that a little bit
but usually when you have a craving for
chocolate if you're a chocoholic or a
sugar or a holic that means that you
have a deficiency if been in a third
world country and Niger in Africa a
chief by the name of Bauer at age 126
was eulogized by one of his wives and
she was bragging about him and his death
at age 126 he was still in possession of
all his own teeth okay so you assume
that other faculties are working too
then here's a gentleman from Syria at
age 133 he died in July of 1993 he
fathered nine children after the age of
80 and this meant if you add up nine
months for each child in a year for
breastfeeding for each one and a year
between each one of the children he was
still fathering children after age of a
hundred so there's still hope for you
fellows then those of you who like
science in November of 1993 those six
biosphere Ian's came out of that dome in
Arizona they were in there for two years
three couples and they were supposed to
eat the perfect food and recycle the
atmosphere and grow their own food and
whatnot and have no pollution in their
water or air or food and when they came
out there examined by medical
gerontologist from UCLA University of
California Los Angeles they put all this
information their physical their blood
work and so forth into the medical
computers at UCLA
medical computers projected that they
could live to be a hundred and
sixty-five years old if they continued
to do what they were doing so all of
that just says to you that there's a
there's a possibility you can live to be
a hundred and twenty and when I grew up
on the farm we could grow two hundred
bushels of corn per acre and with all
the labor and all the fertilizer and
everything else you did you could make a
profit if you grew two hundred bushels
per acre but if you only got a hundred
bushels per acre and put out that same
effort in the same fertilizer cost you'd
lose money and so I want you to think
about it the average lifespan for an
American today is seventy five point
five the average lifespan for an MD or a
doctor is fifty eight you want to gain
20 years statistically just don't go to
medical school you want to live to be
120 there's only two basic things it
real simple two things remember number
one you have to avoid the pitfalls you
have to not step on the landmines I call
it and those of you in the military you
know that means you do something stupid
like step on one of those things you
kill yourself wastefully or
unnecessarily and of course if you play
Russian roulette or smoke excessively or
drink excessively or wear a black
sweatshirt and run down the middle of
the highway of two o'clock in the
morning you're gonna get struck by a car
all of those things are foolhardy but
it's amazing how many tens of thousands
of people die in America from doing
those stupid things every year the last
thing I will share with you on that
subject of avoiding the landmines
I'd suggest very strongly to you that
you avoid going to doctors and I'm going
to back up that statement which is a
pretty strong statement from Ralph
Nader's group in January of 1993 just
about a year and a half ago January 13th
he put out a news release based on a
3-year study on the causes of death in
American hospitals and it was fifteen
hundred page report this three year
study and I'm not going to waste your
time or mine by going over the whole
thing word for word but the bottom line
says a lot quote three hundred thousand
Americans are killed each year in
hospitals alone as a result of medical
negligence unquote I'm going to read
that figure again because it's a huge
figure quote three hundred thousand
Americans are killed each year in
hospitals alone as a result of medical
negligence unquote he didn't say slipped
away quietly
collect in a corner somewhere while
they're waiting for an x-ray he is the
word killed when you used the word
killed that means there was a procedure
the doctor was doing went wrong somehow
that means that they gave them a wrong
prescription they put a decimal point in
the wrong spot and gave them an
incorrect dosage these people were
killed 300,000 to appreciate how big a
figure that is you have to compare that
with our military losses in Vietnam over
10 years where we lost fifty six
thousand people over ten years or an
average of only five thousand six
hundred a year on a field of battle
where people had guns and artillery and
explosives trying to kill each other and
millions of people poured out into the
streets and protested that war we had
political anarchy in the last three
years of the war students took over
universities and colleges with guns and
explosives National Guardsmen shot
students at Kent State in Ohio we chased
a president out of the presidency for
5,600 military personnel year and here's
one profession that takes your tax money
in the form of Medicare and Medicaid and
kills 300,000 of us a year according to
Ralph Nader and I believe he me as no
axe to grind and you can go out in the
street any day of the week in any city
and there isn't even a crazy street
preacher out there with a sign that says
protect us from doctors I want you to
think about that folks that's number one
you have to avoid stepping on the
landmines so there's a certain value and
treating yourself when you can while
preventing disease they don't have to
get treated now the second thing you
have to do number two is you have to do
the positive things you have to do the
positive things and I'm going to start
out here by just putting a figure up on
the board and it's the number 90 and you
need 90 nutrients in your diet every day
you need 60 minerals you need 16
vitamins you need 12 essential amino
acids or protein building blocks and you
need three essential fatty acids you
need 90 nutrients in your daily diet
otherwise you're going to get a
deficiency disease if you don't have
them in complete numbers and optimal
amounts I can tell you that I was one of
those
back when I was in college I had a
clipboard we didn't have computers back
then so I had a clipboard and I was one
of those funny guys with glasses and
would walk up and down in the Student
Union there in Columbia and say do you
take vitamins and minerals I'm still
fascinated by that and and of course
people kind of look at you're crazy and
say well yeah I take vitamin E and I'd
wait for him to come up with the other
89 and they didn't they just so I take
vitamin E well today if you ask people
do you take food supplements they say oh
yeah I take tums because that's what you
know they hear all the time
well again you need 90 nutrients if
you're going to make it but the
newspaper is no and then magazines and
TV and radio knows that we're interested
in health and longevity and and
supplements so they all talked to us not
because the medical profession has asked
them to do that in their stead the
medical profession doesn't say hey we're
so busy saving people with surgery and
chemotherapy and radiation and
pharmaceuticals would you please educate
the people on nutrition they do it
because it sells newspapers
well my favorite article of all time
appeared in Time magazine April 6th 1992
and if you haven't read it I'd urge you
to get it out of the school library or
public library and photocopy it stick
one copy on the door in the bathroom and
one on the refrigerator it's a cover
article and it says the real power of
vitamins new research shows they may
help fight cancer heart disease and the
ravages of aging again there's six
positive pages in here there's only one
negative sentence and was issued by a
medical doctor who is asked by the
writer of the article what do you think
what do you think about vitamins and
minerals for people is food supplements
and here's what the doctor said quote
popping vitamins doesn't do you any good
sniffs dr. Victor Herbert a professor of
medicine at New York City's Mount Sinai
Medical School we get all the vitamins
we need in our diets and taking
supplements just gives you expensive
urine unquote well to give you a
Missouri translation of that that means
you're just peeing away your dollars if
you take vitamins and minerals you might
as well wad up your dollars and throw
them in the toilet and flush them away
because you're not getting any redeeming
value from it those quacks are just
taking your money for those vitamins and
minerals that's what he was trying to
say got published so it must be true
right after having done those 17,500
autopsies and 454 species of animal
from around the world and then 3,000
humans and liking to be healthy myself
and having children and grandchildren in
the not-too-distant future
great-grandchildren I'd rather pee out
50 cents or dollar day worth of excess
vitamins and minerals is pretty cheap
insurance if you don't invest in
yourself to the tune of a buck a day for
vitamins and minerals guess what you're
gonna invest in the lifestyle of an MD
somewhere because when you pay the
medical doctor your fee for going to see
him not one penny of that goes to study
how to diagnose or treat or prevent a
catastrophic disease and a little child
like who was in here earlier or how to
prevent or diagnose or treat better
breast cancer or prostate cancer in
adults
guess what that money goes for our pays
the doctor's mortgage makes his Mercedes
payment it pays the tuition for his kids
to go to medical school at have it you
know have it is up in Basten pays the
tuition for his kids to go to law school
at Yale between 1776 in the Second World
War the US government spent 80 million
dollars on health care and health care
research and studies right now we're 1.2
trillion dollars a year for health care
and it's free we all know it's free
right it's not free but we're supposed
to believe it's free and everybody wants
more of it and more free stuff well tell
you what if we used a human-type medical
system for the agricultural industry in
the livestock your hamburger caused 275
dollars a pound on the other hand if you
use the agricultural health system that
we use in animals for humans your
monthly insurance premiums for a family
of five would be ten dollars a month you
take your choice well I believe since
we've made them wealthy through
insurance programs and government
subsidies
I believe they owe us something I
believe they owe us at least as much as
the industry's do according to for
instance recall notices this was started
of course I don't know 25 years ago when
Ralph Nader learned that the Ford Motor
Company had made a Pinto car with a rear
end gas tank that would blow up when you
got hit from behind at 20 miles an hour
fire everybody in the car and when
people complain to Ford Motor Company
they said well you
just dumb for getting in a car accident
we're not gonna pay you for that Ralph
Nader says no it's a faulty design so he
went to a federal court and the judge
agreed with him and through a court
order forced Ford Motor Company to send
everybody a recall notice with a
registered letter bring that car in and
we'll fix it for nothing but they killed
300,000 a year nobody protests as long
as we get are as free and that scares me
that attitude in a rate I've got a bunch
of these recall notices you should have
gotten over the last couple of years
we'll go through them quickly
number one is ulcers how many of you
ever heard that ulcers is caused by
stress okay everybody's heard that if
you don't raise your hand you got
Alzheimer's or your fibbin right well we
knew fifty years ago and in the
veterinary industry that ulcers at least
in pigs was caused by a bacteria called
Helicobacter pylori and of course we
couldn't get one of these high-priced
stomach surgeons from Mayo Clinic in
fact we always used to yell hold the
Mayo when they'd say stuff like that
otherwise your pork chops would be $275
a pound to pay for that kind of surgery
and we learned that with a trace mineral
called bismuth and the tetracycline
antibiotic that we could prevent and
cure those stomach ulcers and pigs
without surgery so that's what we did
cost five bucks to cure a pig of stomach
ulcers with bismuth the trace mineral in
tetracycline well the National
Institutes of Health now not the
National Enquirer but the National
Institutes of Health came out in
February 1994 and said ulcers are caused
by a bacteria called Helicobacter pylori
not stress and they can be cured they
actually use the Cure word in this news
release medical researchers never do
that they always say it shows promising
results or maybe beneficial they use the
Cure word National Institutes of Health
and they say can be cured with a
combination of the trace mineral bismuth
and tetracycline well for those of you
don't know what business comes in you
can get it from any grocery store or
drugstore it's pink about 295 for an
eight ounce bottle and it's called
pepto-bismol so a teaspoon a day full of
pepto-bismol and some are mice and calf
scowler pellets you can take care of
sorts now you have your choice but
you're gonna treat your own for five
bucks or go get whittled on that's your
choice then once the number two cause of
death and
Americans terrible disease called cancer
right now doctors get information on
cancer you'd think they'd photocopy that
when they send you that bill they should
send you some photo copies of this stuff
well in September of 1993 the National
Cancer Institute not the National
Enquirer but the National Cancer
Institute and the have't medical school
up in Boston did study on cancer
patients and they came out and they said
an anti-cancer diet was found well any
rate they picked China to do this study
because in one province Henan Province
in China they have the highest rate of
cancer in the whole world
they took 29,000 people for five years
in this study and what they did was give
them different vitamins and minerals had
doubled the recommended daily allowance
for Americans now that's a trivial
amount for instance they used vitamin C
for one group and of course the RDA
recommended daily allowance for vitamin
C is 60 milligrams double des can be 120
milligrams you can't go into a health
food store and find a vitamin C tablet
or capsule for less than 500 milligrams
for an adult and of course Linus Pauling
the gentleman with two Nobel Prizes says
if you want to prevent and treat cancer
with vitamin C you got to use ten
thousand milligrams a day well all the
doctors he used to argue with him back
thirty five years ago were all dead and
today Linus Pauling still 94 and he
works 14 hours a day seven days a week
on his ranch in the Big Sur in
California and teaches at the University
of California San Francisco so you have
to make up your choice whether you're
going to listen to the dead doctors or
Linus Pauling your choice
okay vitamin C double the RDA nothing
happened vitamin A double the RDA
nothing happens zinc riboflavin the
trace mineral molybdenum nice and
nothing happened in one group they got a
major benefit in this group they got
three nutrients at one time they got
vitamin E
they got beta-carotene and the trace
mineral selenium there those three were
at double the RDA and if you get a half
a percent benefit in any nutritional or
pharmaceutical experiment you've made a
major improvement in humanity's life and
so these articles get published so once
you remember that statistic a half a
percent is major benefit well in this
group that received the vitamin D
beta-carotene and selenium for five
years deaths from all causes where we do
by nine percent almost 10 out of every
hundred or one out of every ten who were
going to die in that five years from any
cause survived then cancers all cancers
13 percent survived who would have died
without those three nutrients so 13 out
of a hundred lived who would have died
and then the type of cancer that was
most prevalent in Henan Province stomach
and esophageal cancer 21 percent lived
who would have died 21 out of a hundred
lived now to me those are significant
numbers and your physician for the
number two cause of death in America
should have sent every one of you a
photocopy that at least given the
information even if he doesn't want to
give you the advice give you the
information let you make up your own
mind well here's one I think is funny on
one hand and on the other side it tells
you the attitude of physicians this has
to do with arthritis it was in September
24th 1993 that it was released again it
was from the habit medical school in the
Basten VA hospital how many of you in
here have ever been to a VA hospital
anybody in this room okay good well you
know the people who've been to a VA
hospital we have two opportunities to
give your life for your country
once on the field of battle and the
others in the VA hospital right well
narrate the title of the release was
chicken protein halts to swelling and
pain of arthritis in a patient trial and
what they did they took people who
failed to respond in any way to medical
treatment for arthritis these people got
gold shots mezzo Trek's eight they got
aspirin prednisone cortisone everything
else you can think of physical therapy
and the only thing left for them was
joint replacement surgery okay now
before Harvard Medical School the VA
hospital was going to give it to him
they said look we're looking for some
people who are willing to suffer for 90
more days just three months because we
want to try something a short-term
experiment and they got 29 volunteers
and what they did for those 29
volunteers who failed to respond in any
way to medical treatment for arthritis
was they gave them a heaping teaspoon
full of ground-up dried chicken
cartilage in their orange juice every
morning just a heaping teaspoon of
ground up chicken cartilage and in ten
days according to Harvard Medical School
all the pain and inflammation was gone
these are people who didn't respond in
any way to medical treatment in 30 days
they could open up a new pickle jar that
never been opened
and ninety days three months they had
maximum return of function here's the
funny part
the funny part comes by a statement of
the guy who was the director of that
study from Harvard Medical School and
here's what he said quote listen to the
words a very important quote after three
months it was clear that the drug was
beneficial unquote because it worked
chicken cartilage had become a drug you
can see he's thinking about patent
numbers and his eyes are rolling around
with 300 bucks a capsule twenty patients
and you just see him calculating right
that means if you go to Kentucky Fried
Chicken and you buy a bucket of chicken
throw away the skin and the meat and eat
the ends off the bones you're practicing
medicine without a license and if you go
to a Kentucky Fried Chicken in the
middle of the night and the dark of the
night and you go to their dumpster and
your route through there and you collect
two 5-gallon feed buckets full of
chicken bones and you take them home
with a hammer and you pound off the ends
of those bones and dry your own
cartilage in the microwave you know
you're manufacturing a pharmaceutical
and the FDA is gonna put you in jail
next time I come by here in three months
you're gonna run up on this stage and
hug me and kiss me if you got arthritis
how many you've ever heard of alzheimers
disease everybody's heard about it today
50 years ago when I was a little kid
there's no such thing as a high murmurs
disease it's a new disease one of those
things that just sort of happened now
it's a major disease one out of every
two people who reach age 70 get
alzheimer's disease it's pretty scary we
learned fifty years ago in the animal
industry how to prevent and cure in the
early stages alzheimers disease in
livestock you imagine how much a farmer
would lose if the pigs were all laying
there scratching their head saying why
am I here
where is the feed box because if they're
not gaining a couple of pounds a day
you're losing money right so we learned
in the agricultural industry how to
prevent in the early stages cure
Alzheimer's disease and we do it with
high doses of vitamin E and low intakes
of vegetable oil you say well like
that's crazy high doses of vitamin E
well you should have got a recall notice
from your doctor in July of 1992 because
the University of California I mean
we're talking about a sophisticated
research medical school here University
of California San Diego came out and
said vitamin E eases memory loss and
alzheimerís victims there are only 50
years behind on that from veterinary
medicine so he might be safer going to a
veterinarian then how many of you in
this room ever had a kidney stone
anybody in here ever get that kidney
stone okay I see a few in here what's
the first thing a doctor told you to
give up nutritionally when you got your
kidney stone give up calcium no dairy no
dairy
none of those vitamin mineral things
with calcium in them because they have
the stupid naive ignorant belief as
pretty intense they have the stupid
ignorant naive belief that the calcium
in your kidney stone comes from the
calcium you eat when in fact it comes
from your own bones when you have a
raging calcium deficiency a raging
osteoporosis then you get kidney stones
we learned years ago in writing in the
agricultural industry if you wanted to
prevent kidney stones in livestock you
better give them more calcium you better
give them more magnesium and more boron
the reason is of course bulls and rams
male cattle and sheep have special
anatomy when they get a kidney stone
they die they called water belly they
died when you and I get a kidney stone
we just wish we were dead but no farmer
is dumb enough to pay for the feed for
an animal and have it die before you can
either eat it or send it to market so we
learned how to prevent those things well
you should have got a recall notice from
your doctor especially you people who've
had kidney stones your urologist should
have sent a notice to you this was March
of 1993 it says calcium limits kidney
stone risk and this is from the have't
medical school up in Boston by the way
in a study that turns conventional
medical wisdom on its head researchers
have found that people whose diets are
rich in calcium run a reduced risk of
developing kidney stones and studied
more than 45,000 people though who were
ranked
into five categories the group that had
the most calcium had no kidney stones
now about five years ago when I started
out on this crusade and started
lecturing to people all across America
and I'm in one timezone in the next and
all over I knew I was going to get crazy
out there doing this last year I was on
the road 300 days out of the year 300
out of 365 days and so I decided I
needed to have a hobby that I could take
with me every time I get a little wacko
I could go in my room and do this hobby
and I'd be okay you know be kind of like
having a little piece of home with me
wherever I went I wanted to have a hobby
that would help other people I didn't
want to collect baseball cards because I
like football and I didn't want to do
just crossword puzzles because a good
mental exercise but wouldn't help
anybody else and I couldn't take my
compost pile I like the garden and the
hotels don't like that you know so I
decided I was going to collect
obituaries of doctors and lawyers
now as crazy as that sounds remember I
told you the doctors lived to an average
age of 58 and we live to seventy five
point five and here's a group of people
professionals who pontificate you and
tell you well this is what you need to
do you need to give up salt and no
caffeine and you need to not eat butter
and eat margarine and do all these crazy
things and they die at age 58 on the
average anybody got a few of them here
some of my favorites so this dr. Stuart
Cartwright age 38 he dropped dead in his
home he was a family practitioner of a
ruptured aneurysm that's a ballooning of
an artery that's a weakened artery
because of the fragmenting or the
brittle condition of the elastic fibers
and arteries just like when you hit a
chuckhole with your car tire and you
break the cords in there and you get a
balloon he dropped dead like he was
poleaxed okay right in his home from a
ruptured aneurysm and we learned in 1900
I think it was 57 aneurysms are caused
by a copper deficiency we had a pilot
project turkeys we made complete food
pellets where you put all the 90
nutrients in there and in the first 13
weeks fully half of those turkeys died
farmers were out there every morning
picking them up by the bushel basket
they took them to the state diagnostic
labs and their autopsy and they found
out that they all had died from a
ruptured aortic aneurysm so they doubled
the amount of copper in there and the
next year they didn't lose a single
turkey from a ruptured aortic aneurysm
and they ran that experiment in mice and
rats and rabbits and dogs and cats and
calves and sheep and pigs and whatnot
and guess what they found out there's a
whole series of diseases that are caused
by a copper deficiency gray hair is the
first time we started getting gray hair
regardless of your age you got a copper
deficiency you get skin wrinkles because
the elastic fibers in your skin are
going those little crow's feet around
your eyes and facial and body skin
wrinkles you look like you're a little
prune drying up okay then of course
there's the varicose veins that's caused
by an elastic fiber breakdown then of
course parts of your body begin to Sag
under your arms your breasts your
bellies your legs all this stuff starts
sagging and you go to a cosmetic surgeon
or plastic surgeon if you want
but it's a lot cheaper and a lot more
effective and a lot safer he just takes
some copper
dr. Cartwright may have had a medical
degree but he didn't have expensive
urine so he died of something that even
a turkey wouldn't die from then here's
one this fellow he was a doctor's doctor
dr. Martin Carter he almost made it he
died at age 57 he got his medical degree
from have't medical school and his PhD
in medicine from Yale
he was autopsy by the best because he
was a doctors doctor said quote the
cause of death was a ruptured aortic
aneurysm said dr. Jules Hirsch at the
Rockefeller University Hospital unquote
where did he die from copper deficiency
see he didn't have expensive urine
either then here's an attorney
she was so famous she was from Detroit
age 44 Ellen Joyce alter she was in the
New York Times obituary she made the big
time and of course she probably had
steel buns because she belonged to one
of those private health clubs all these
gals want steel buns you know doing
their little exercises but she didn't
have expensive urine because she died of
a ruptured cerebral aneurysm when they
don't do an autopsy the symptoms could
be called a stroke or subdural
hemorrhage but very frequently they're
caused by a ruptured aneurysm which is a
copper deficiency she didn't have
expensive urine how many of you were
here I've ever heard of a guy by the
name of stewart burger stuart burger he
he wrote five best-selling books on
health and diets and nutrition he got
his medical degree from Tufts Medical
School which is a very fine Medical
School in Boston not too far away from
Harvard Medical School and the books he
wrote included the Southampton diet for
weight loss
he wrote Forever Young 20 years younger
in 20 weeks and how to be your own
nutritionist and he died at age 40 how'd
you like to follow his dietary practices
he died at age 40 of cardiomyopathy
which is a selenium deficiency the same
causes white muscle disease or our stiff
lamb disease and any farmer can go to a
feed store and get selenium pellets or
selenium injections of things like cell
Ataka and Bazzi and so forth
and dr. Stewart burger guy who wrote
five best-selling books on nutrition
died of a nutritional deficiency he
didn't have expensive urine
you can prevent totally prevent
cardiomyopathy for 10 cents a day and if
we don't do it we're malignant dumb I
like to call it your malignant dumb if
you don't take in 10 cents a day worth
of selenium it's a waste of your life
that's one of those landmines you can
avoid the medical treatment of choice
for cardiomyopathy is a heart transplant
caused seven hundred and fifty thousand
dollars I want you to think about that
they get the heart free from a donor
they get the blood free for the surgery
from the relatives they use 2 dollars
and 50 cents worth of suture material
and they charges 750 thousand dollars
for that procedure now 6 months ago in
LA when they had the earthquake they
were putting people in jail for 60 and
90 days for price gouging for selling
these terrified people a gallon of water
for $4 they put him in jail for price
gouging for selling him a gallon of
water for 4 bucks now to me that's
entrepreneurial ISM you know that's
being in business for yourself if you
had a way to distill water and make
water and you had a car and you could
get in there and sell those people a
gallon of water for 4 bucks hey more
power to you because if you go to a
7-eleven and buy a quart of Evian water
it's a dollar 29 so four of those quarts
is a five bucks kind of interesting
isn't it
they said it's price gouging because
those people were terrified we'll talk
about a person who needs a new heart
they're terrified 750 thousand dollars
we should put those doctors in jail but
we bow to him because all that's
high-tech medicine out of 270 million
people in America you save about 50 a
year is that cost-effective I don't
think so
dr. Stuart Berger didn't have expensive
urine here's the last one and many of
you may know this woman her name is dr.
Gail Clark she was age 47 she was the
chief cardiologist at the West st. Louis
County group of hospitals she was the
chief cardiologist for the st. Mary's
health center in Richmond Heights in st.
Louis County she's aged 47 guess what
she died from heart attack a
cardiomyopathy heart attack you can just
see her walking down the hall she's got
the stethoscope around her neck you know
this is their little status symbol got
my stethoscope around my neck back when
I was in school they folded it up very
bravely and put it in their pocket when
she falls down she has a heart attack
right in the hall and of course the
nurses scooped her up
on a gurney and they call the
technicians in another docker code 3
code 3 code blue whatever it is and they
whip her into the room and you can hear
let's say you're a cardiac patient
you're laying there you're all hooked up
to the monitors and the IVs and and you
hear them saying okay
tear it close over okay stand back
didn't work turn it up stand back and
then you hear that terrible sound when
you know that the treatment didn't work
the flatline when you know the heart is
gone and everybody walks out of the room
dejected and you say nurse nurse what
happened next door and she says well
your cardiologist you know the chief
cardiologist to this hospital age 47 dr.
Gail Clark just died of a cardiac with a
heart attack we can see all the patients
are holding their gowns and they're
running out of that hospital leaving
their watches and their shoes and their
checkbooks and everything their plastic
credit cards because they don't want to
get what dr. Gail Clark got to me the
Reader's Digest is a magazine that never
says anything negative or bad about
anybody or any group
it's a sweetest little magazine that
ever was the September 1993 issue
features an article it says can you
trust your doctor
it lists 12 ways the doctors scam your
money now I'll let you read 11 of them
yourself I'll give you the worst one in
addition to their income from office
fees and surgical fees and lab fees and
hospitalization doctors get a kickback
from the labs and the the x-ray labs and
clinics and hospitals they get a
kickback of 421 dollars every time they
send you in for a cat scan or an MRI and
doctors tell you all we do that because
we're practicing defensive medicine
because if I miss something you know one
in ten billion you're gonna sue me so I
do this just to protect myself well if
it was just to protect themselves and
you knew them and they knew you ninety
percent of the people say I'll just skip
it doctor you don't really think it's
necessarily save the money but they got
something more than defensive medicine
to worry about they get 421 bucks in a
kickback for every time they send you in
for an MRI or a cat scan well when I
practice for twelve years up in Portland
somebody come to me with a terrible
headache never had one I just walk up to
him and tap them on the sinuses and if
they'd collapsed to their knees I know
they had a sinus headache Oh doc why did
you do that well I smart that's a cheap
lab test you know then if they had thank
you if they had blood dripping out of
their nose that take a $35 x-ray to see
if they had a cancer in their 35 bucks
in a free lab test as opposed to 421
bucks if I wanted to make that 421 bucks
I'd have been a good thief what I'd have
done I had to build a chute right into
that cat scan machine because I knew how
to build chutes living on a farm and I
did going out in the street and I got
every homeless person I'd line them up
in them chutes and I'd put soup and a
Big Mac at the end of that tube you know
and I say I'm gonna get by you a dollar
fifty dinner I'm a good guy I'm gonna
buy you a dollar fifty dinner you just
got to go through this chute go through
that tube and you get your sandwich in
your soup man they'd be flowing through
there maybe a hundred a day and I can
start adding some things up it'd be a
lot of fun any rate the average doctor
gets two hundred and twenty eight
thousand six hundred and sixty dollars a
year in cat-scan kickbacks a quarter of
a million dollars a year and any other
industry if you do that politicians
lawyers businessmen stockbrokers they
get plucking job but doctors it's okay
because insurance pays for it we don't
mind if they steal is blind it's free
remember I told you I was gonna tell you
about Piko Piko is a funny disease P ICA
I'm going to talking about the type
style that you see in typewriters and
computers but pikas a disease that
farmers know about in horses it's called
cribbing when they chew on the feed bunk
the wooden feed bunk
you know you better give them some
minerals otherwise they're and eat that
feed bunk and cattle dairy cattle
especially where they're losing lots of
minerals through their milk all the time
intensive milking you'll see them
picking up big rocks in the creek and
chewing on them or they'll chew on Bob
wire or maybe you'll see them walking
down through a path with a deer bone in
their mouth or something or a shingle
that's called pica and a good farmer
husbandry man knows you better give them
some minerals otherwise they're gonna
eat the barn or something
in human beings we see this at funny
times pregnant women are notorious for
pike ax the middle of the night they'll
elbow with her husband and say hey you
better get up I want some pickles and
ice cream they're craving minerals
that fetus is pulling minerals out of
their body they need some more minerals
and so it's is recognized as a craving
for things like sweets and salt we see
this in pregnant women I used to have
people come to my practice and they say
doc do I need to go see a shrink I said
why is that well I wake up in the middle
of the night and I go outside with a
spoon and I eat dirt no that's okay just
make sure it's clean dirt then they say
my kid sits there with a kitty litter
box between his legs and he has a spoon
and he's eating that stuff I the kitty
litter box and then in housing projects
little kids will eat lead paint off the
walls and they get lead poisoning at
learning disabilities and bone problems
in a Nemean we're good so we spend 5
million dollars to scrape the lead paint
off of there and repaint it with latex
paint we only have to do is give those
kids 10 cents a day worth of minerals be
better farm and save us 5 million bucks
it's your tax money and if we allow them
to throw them away those dollars is kind
of interesting if you have a selenium
deficiency and you don't want to wait
until you get to cardiomyopathy and drop
dead from a heart attack to recognize it
if you look on your hands and look in
the mirror in your face if you have
liver spots or age spots and I see quite
a few from here you have an early
selenium deficiency that's called free
radical damage and fortunately for you
if you recognize that and you start
taking in some selenium in 4 to 6 months
as a little away you'll reverse that in
4 to 6 months and when they go away on
the outside they're going away on the
inside and your brain and your heart in
your liver and your kidneys and if you
have low blood sugar how many in this
room have a low blood sugar or anybody
in here have low blood sugar ok about
10% how many of you ever seen a
hyperactive kid who gets on sugar ok
about everybody in the room people who
have sugar problems are like alcoholics
there's good ones and bad ones
you know the good alcoholics are one
when they get 2 drinks they just go off
in a corner and go to sleep right same
way with somebody with low blood sugar
they eat a big meal or they eat a piece
of pie three hours later they clunk out
and go to sleep then there's bad
alcoholics are the one that gets two
drinks in them and they get violent and
raged and they want to fight everybody
punch holes in the wall you know big
brave fellows and they kick their wife
and kick the dog and take the chainsaw
and cut their neighbors tree down and
all these wild things and drive reckless
down the roads and kill people those are
the bad drunks
people who have blood sugar problems
there's bad blood sugar people to be a
little crazy okay I don't know how many
of you remember the Twinkie defense
right remember if somebody murdered two
people and he claimed he ate a Twinkie
three hours before he murdered them so
they let him off because he got
temporarily insane every time he ate
sugar now don't any of you try that
well chromium and vanadium deficiency
will result in these sugar problems low
blood sugar and if you let it go on for
any length of time you develop diabetes
chromium and vanadium then attend
deficiency the early symptoms of a10
deficiency are male pattern baldness I
see a lot of tin deficiency in this room
yes and if you let it go on for any
length of time you get deafness then
there's a boron deficiency and you Gallo
should know about boron because it helps
you keep the calcium you take in and
your bones so you don't get osteoporosis
boron also it helps you make estrogen it
helps you fellas make testosterone if
you don't take in enough boron you
ladies are gonna suffer miserably going
through menopause okay you're gonna have
all those terrible symptoms you fellas
don't get enough boron can't make
testosterone you won't know whether to
lead or follow on the dance floor
you're gonna be confused she's saying
he's got a boron deficiency the first
symptoms of a zinc deficiency as you
lose your sense of smell and your taste
say oh you know food just doesn't taste
good anymore you don't have a cold or
anything like that you say your wife
says well aren't you excited about
dinner I spent the whole day in the
kitchen cooking dinner he says I didn't
smell anything when I walked in you know
he's got a zinc deficiency when
laboratory animals there's some seven
rare earths these rare earths or trace
minerals you need in lesser amounts than
you need trace minerals and they
actually double the lifespan of
laboratory animals they've not been
proven in humans yet but I'm not going
to wait five hundred years for doctors
to approve it they're still arguing over
vitamin C and calcium right so I'm just
going to do it didn't kill any
laboratory animals just doubles her life
and it's not a drug these rare earths
are called lanthanum precio die Miam
neodymium samarium europium ytterbium
and thulium there must be a reason why
they're named after old testament cities
well remember I told you we needed 90
nutrients we need 60 minerals we need 16
vitamins twelve essential amino acids
and three essential fatty acids and of
course we're lucky in that plants as a
group can make most vitamins amino acids
and fatty acids plants can do that
because they just take carbon out of the
air and make carbon chains to make
vitamins amino acids and fatty acids but
you have to eat 15 to 25 different
plants a day in the right combinations
to make this happen theoretically as
possible but most Americans don't do it
the average American thinks if they eat
some potato buds out of a Betty Crocker
box or eaten a vegetable in case oh you
got to be careful what you're
considering a vegetable then of course
people want to do right by their doctor
and they eat low-fat turkey breasts and
they put a half a jar of mayonnaise on
there and they put it between two slices
of wonder styrofoam bread remember that
stuff you can insulate your house with
and put your shoes when you get a whole
and shoe I remember when I was a kid
there's a lot of fun because we have
Wonder Bread we didn't have TVs back
then on the farm we didn't even have
dryers that went round and round so the
only thing you could do in the
wintertime was sit in the kitchen and
wonder
loaf of Wonder Bread and had the blue
and red and green yellow balloons on
there and if you read the label as many
times as I do you know it said things
like helps build bodies at twelve ways
in about fifteen years later the FDA
made them change it to help build your
body eight ways now if you go to the
store and look at Wonder bread wrappers
it just says Wonder Bread so it kind of
gives you a clue so even though this is
theoretically possible it is not likely
to happen that you're going to get your
vitamins amino acids and fatty acids and
proper proportions from your diet and so
if your life is as valuable to you as
mine is to me and my children's and my
grandchildren's is to me I would make
sure that I take in all my vitamins and
amino acids and fatty acids because I
guarantee you won't make it to a hundred
and twenty if you don't you're just not
going to do it now minerals are another
story we have a tragic story when it
comes to minerals because plants cannot
make minerals in any way shape or form
and if they're not in the soil anymore
they're not in our plants there are farm
soils and our rain soils are depleted of
minerals in the crops the grains the
fruits and the vegetables and the nuts
that are growing on these depleted farm
and rain soils are mineral deficient the
people who eat them get mineral
deficiency diseases and the only way to
prevent and cure them is with mineral
supplements you think it's gotten any
better no it has not gotten any better
it's only gotten worse and the reason is
if you guys do what we did and people
continue to do is we put NPK on our land
nitrogen phosphorus potassium and you
see it as these three numbers in many
combinations of ratios and these
represent percentages of these three
nutrients nitrogen phosphorus potassium
and those of you who don't have any
experience on farms the reason why we do
this as farmers get paid for tons and
bushels
there's no subsidy that encourages
people to put sixty minerals back in the
soil you get paid for tons and bushels
and for 40 bucks an acre you can get the
maximum yield in tons and bushels it
only takes five to ten years to deplete
the land of minerals because every time
you harvest a crop those plants pull
minerals out of the soil many pounds per
acre every time you hole a crop out so
as soon those minerals are gone and if
you only put back in three and you take
out sixty it's like a checking account
if you only put three bucks in your
checking account
every month and write checks for 60
what's going to happen to your checks
Boeing Boeing Boeing they bounce exactly
well I can tell you that our health is
bouncing right now to the tune of 1.2
trillion dollars a year it's our
responsibility each and every one of us
to be responsible for our health and
consciously take in these minerals I
have a lot of people ask me well what
did these people do thousands of years
ago they didn't even have commercial
fertilizers what did they do these
societies that had long lived people and
whatnot I want you to think about the
Egyptians the Chinese people from India
that lived around these great rivers the
Nile River the Ganges River the Yellow
River in China and what used to happen
was every year or so would flood just
like it did here in northern Missouri
last year and every time it flooded
guess what would happen it would bring
silt or rock dust from mountains from
five hundred or thousand miles away and
those people would pray to every God
they had the water God the sky God the
wind God the rock God to flood we pray
don't flood they used to pray to flood
because they had their floods during the
wintertime and it would put silt and
minerals back in the soil and their
drain was very valuable King Phillip
who's the father of Alexander the Great
married the 12 year old child queen of
Egypt Cleopatra she didn't look like
Elizabeth Taylor all made up in
beautiful costumes she was a little
flat-chested teeny bopper not very sexy
but Philip married her because she
controlled the best wheat in the world
and if he wanted his Macedonian army to
conquer the world through his son
Alexander the Great he needed the best
wheat in the world so you could march 20
hours a day fight for six hours and win
if they used the wheat from the depleted
soils in Greece they couldn't go 20
minutes without saying mommy pick me up
he imagined these big Greek soldiers all
my legs hurt pick me up and so they knew
the best place to get wheat was from
Egypt it was those floods that gave them
those minerals and all those cultures
that came up with all the great art and
all the great technology came from those
places because they had more
intelligence because they had more
nutrition more minerals I heard somebody
say very good we are getting the picture
well what I'm gonna do here is I'm just
gonna pick out a couple of minerals just
a couple of them so you get the idea it
applies to all of them let's just pick
out a common one
like calcium everybody knows about
calcium calcium deficiency will result
in something like a hundred and forty
seven different diseases they're just
different names are named after people
like Bell's palsy you know everybody
knows about that one side of your face
sags it's not as true stroke it just
affects your facial muscles it's caused
by calcium deficiency we'll talk about
in a little bit
everybody knows about this one
osteoporosis it's the number 10 killer
of adults United States it's very
expensive it cost you thirty five
thousand dollars each for each hip to
replace it's okay it's free insurance
will pay for it cost you seventy
thousand dollars for both hips as
expensive as it is and the number ten
killer remember mister Skeets from
Radford Virginia ages one hundred and
fifteen years of age she died of
complications of a fall we don't have
osteoporosis and animals and it's
because of farmers we don't have
osteoporosis and animals goes like this
you have a pasture with a hundred cows
in it and this year you didn't have any
calves you can't repay your operating
loan you're in trouble right because you
paid for the feed and the vet bill and
mowed the pasture and fertilize and
maintain the fence and fed the cows and
all this that in the other you don't
have any calves you can't pay back the
operating low and make any money so you
call the vet out you say do I get rid of
these cows what happened here and he
examines the college there's nothing
wrong with them says let me look at the
bull and said aha
here's your problem that bull has
osteoporosis of both hips can't breed
the cows didn't have any calves he says
I'll tell you what though he says you
give me $70,000 he says I'll put two new
hips in that bull next year you'll have
some calves well the first thing that
farmer says - stand back doc boom he
blows that bull away with a deer rifle
and well the kids are grinding the bull
up with a grinder and cutting roasts and
steaks off that bull the farmers chewing
on a straw and saying now doc pushes
Stetson up a little bit and he says you
know I wasn't gonna pay you seventy
thousand dollars for that old boy says I
get a new bull every year for seventy
years for that he says but every once
while I get a bullet throws good calves
I'd like to keep him is there any way I
can prevent that osteoporosis thing for
happen to a good boy says well yeah he
says if you'll give a bull calf ten
cents worth of calcium every day after
he's weaned he'll never get osteoporosis
first in a wait a minute doc you mean if
I give that bull ten cents a day worth
of calcium from the time he's weaned I
can prevent
a thousand dollar disaster oh yeah it's
that simple
he says you mean all I have to do is
give up a half a cup of coffee a day to
do that he says yeah that's it he says I
choose that one he said I'll give up the
half a cup of coffee and that's what we
have to think like then there's receding
gums dentist and periodontist will tell
you that if you want to prevent and cure
receding gums you better floss and brush
after every meal if you believe that
works I have some oceanfront property in
Montana to sell you if you all know your
geography you know that doesn't work now
as a veterinarian I've seen hundreds of
thousands of animals of all kinds mice
rats rabbits dogs cats sheep pigs horses
lines and tigers and bears and they
don't get receding gums and they don't
floss now they do get funky breath but
they don't get receding gums well if you
want to smell some you just let a camel
breathe on you boy well the reason we
don't have receding gums and livestock
is because we've dealt with the
osteoporosis problem receding gums is
not a deficiency of flossing it's in
fact osteoporosis of the jaw bones and
of the facial bones so if you have Ginja
virus or receding gums you have advanced
osteoporosis those bones around your
teeth are melting away a little bit by a
little bit every day and if you take
your teeth out at night and put them in
a glass next to your bed and that fizzy
stuff you have major advanced
osteoporosis because all your bone has
melted away
then there's arthritis we talked about
that a little bit earlier remember the
chicken cartilage 85% of all arthritis
is caused by ice tio Prosis of the joint
ends of the bone you're talking about
degenerative arthritis osteoarthritis
sciatica lumbago rheumatism all those
sorts of things they're caused by
osteoporosis of the joint ends of the
bones I want you to think about
something for a minute if you don't take
a pain reliever or an anti-inflammatory
for that arthritis let's say you get
arthritis of the hips you're gonna kind
of favor that a little bit aren't you
you're gonna get a cane or a walker or
crutches
you're gonna favor it so you don't put
any weight on it I want you to think
about that for just a second because
they don't want you to think about
driving your tractor in a field or
you're driving a Mercedes down the
highway either one doesn't matter
whichever you love more let's say you
didn't put the nut on that oil pan real
tighten all the oil drained
and that light on the dashboard comes on
says I'm getting hot you better give me
some oil and that light irritates you so
you stop you open up the hood you get
your Clippers out you know your fence
clippers and you clip the wire to that
light you close the hood and you just
keep driving would you do that to your
tractor your Mercedes no you would we
take those pain relievers for arthritis
and we go out there and square dance and
do the Texas two-step and do our
five-mile walk so our aerobics that pill
works real good doc because it killed my
pain and you're just wearing that thing
off faster and faster then your doctor
is really gonna get rich because you
need joint replacement surgery then
there's hypertension this is one of my
favorites so I'll put a star over here
hypertension is high blood pressure
what's the first nutritional thing that
a doctor will tell you to give up
nutritionally when you get high blood
pressure give up salt everybody knows
that when that's been ingrained in our
head well they must think we're dumber
than cows because what's the first thing
you put out for your livestock and about
that big a salt block no farmer is gonna
be economically viable if you don't put
a salt block out for your livestock
they're gonna die kind of your
veterinary bills are gonna go crazy but
we're supposed to believe that we don't
need salt you can get everything you
need out of your lettuce and your
whole-wheat bread and stuff like that
well don't believe that one either if
you believe that I got some more
oceanfront property in Montana for you
they took thirty million dollars of your
tax money and two years ago after 20
years study they came out and said that
they took five thousand people with high
blood pressure they took him off their
medication and put him on a reduced salt
diet a restricted salt diet and they all
died
no big surprise but somebody got a PhD
degree and everybody was happy right but
when they looked at this results they
said that only ninety-nine point seven
percent of the people didn't get any
results from that before they died 0.3
percent did get some result dropped
their blood pressure one point before
they died by restricting their salt so
the referees who judged that article
said Oh doesn't matter you might as well
let high blood pressure patients he
salted peanuts and dill pickles and salt
their food to taste because it doesn't
matter
in fact worrying about the salt is more
stress than taking the salt then they
had a control group with 5,000 people
with high blood pressure and they
doubled their RDA of calcium and they
stopped the experiment in six weeks
because 85% of them were cured of their
high
pressure just by doubling their calcium
intake now they didn't cold turkey stop
their high blood pressure medication but
what they did was they went to the
doctor he says you don't need this
medication anymore what are you doing
well I'm on this experiment I double my
calcium intake anybody get a recall
notice from your doctors saying it's
okay to salt your food to taste and
please do double your calcium intake
anybody get that not a single one is
very interesting then of course there's
insomnia that's where you roll around
all night when you wake up in the
morning you're more tired when you went
to bed that's insomnia of course doctors
have two treatments for that they have
Halcyon which is a sleeping pill and
they have barbiturates they kill about
10,000 people a year with overdoses of
those things but that's okay
it's a prescription and they're watching
out for us and remember George Bush when
he went to Japan they gave him some
healthy on so he could sleep on the way
to Japan because of the time difference
and when he woke up one of the side
effects of Halcyon is nausea and
vomiting I don't know how you say it in
Japanese but it was very dramatic on
world TV right not very presidential
blood and so I'm sure that's why he lost
the election because he puked over that
Japanese ambassador and then of course
there's kidney stones and then there is
a bone spurs heel spurs and calcium
deposits again physicians will tell you
the first thing to give up nutritionally
is calcium and dairy because they have
this foolish belief the stupid belief
the ignorant belief that the calcium in
kidney stones bone spurs heel spurs and
calcium deposits come from their diet
when instead it only comes from your
bones when you have a raging
osteoporosis and when you get these
things you need more calcium not less
then there's cramps and twitches you
wake up in the middle of the night and
your foot is all cramped up around your
neck you say Lord take me from the knee
down I'm not going to make it till
morning we've all experienced that
that's very common then there's PMS
premenstrual syndrome you know he's the
emotional and physical stuff the medical
treatment of choice for PMS is what we
call a hysterical ectomy it's been
shortened to hysterectomy that's a
hundred-year-old treatment doctors do
about 285
5,000 unnecessary hysterical ectomy a
year but it makes Mercedes payments so
they do them even the AMA said they're
unnecessary but they don't take their
licenses away and people keep going to
them you imagine a poor woman in her 30s
she says doc you got to do something
every time I go out to hang up the
clothes my neighbors kids run down the
basement screaming which my own kids
think I'm crazy my husband's leaving me
I'm gonna lose my job you got to do
something well the University of
California San Diego came out three
years ago now and said if you just
doubled the RDA of calcium intake you
get rid of 85% of the emotional and
physical symptoms of PMS and when that
came out there were huge lines around
the health food stores around the blocks
and people had sleeping bags because it
closed before they all got their calcium
and every person in line was a man
they were there for their daughters and
their girlfriends and their wives and
things like that okay and lastly is low
back pain 85% of Americans get low back
pain with your work on a computer or you
unload hay or you drive big trucks
doesn't matter low back is a big problem
low back is just osteoporosis of the
vertebra whether you have a disc problem
or what not because if your disc doesn't
have anything to hold on to your
vertebrae have melted away what's going
to happen to the discs especially if you
have a copper deficiency because they're
made out of elastic fibers they go like
a water balloon with a lot of pressure
on them I just want you to look at this
quickly before we do the last mineral
low back you go to an orthopedic surgeon
or rheumatologist you might get a muscle
relaxant you might get valium and a
muscle relaxant you get the laminectomy
you get your vertebrae fuse you might
get a disc operation they don't tell you
75% of time you'll never be the same
again
right PMS you go to your ob/gyn you can
go to an internist you go to a family
counselor a shrink or divorce attorney
cramps and twitches you go to a
neurologist you go to a sports medicine
doctor and in turn us bone spurs heel
spurs calcium deposits you go to a
Rheumatologist an orthopedic surgeon or
a podiatrist kidney stones you go to a
urologist or an internist or a surgeon
insomnia you go to shrinker a sleep
clinic or an internist hypertension you
go to a cardiologist and internist or a
surgeon arthritis a Rheumatologist a
orthopedic surgeon or an internist
receding gums you go to a dentist or a
periodontist osteoporosis you go to all
those health specialists including a tum
salesman for nothing more than a calcium
deficiency it cost you ten cents a day
to deal with now on the average because
Americans have insurance and we have
Medicare and Medicaid we spend on the
average $25,000 to two hundred and fifty
thousand dollars and we undergo five to
ten surgical procedures a year for a
calcium deficiency we beg the doctors to
do it we beg the doctors to do it well
it's our choice the last one I'll share
with you is diabetes
everybody is touched by diabetes it's
the number three cause of death and
adults in the United States number three
cause of death
and it has terrible complications and
side effects diabetes the side effects
include blindness of many kinds then
there's a kidney failure with dialysis
and kidney transplant
there's cardiovascular disease of all
kinds and of course that contributes the
number one cause of death then there is
amputations everybody ought to have one
of those because they're totally paid
for in their health thing because they
assume that you're not just gonna get
one because you want to get everything
on your health benefits and then you
shorten your life because if you have
diabetes on the average you have a
shorter life span than someone who
doesn't have diabetes now we learned in
1957 in the animal industry that we
could prevent and cure diabetes with -
trace minerals that's pretty profound
statement we could prevent and cure
diabetes with - trace minerals in 1957
in animals it was published in
Federation proceedings which is the
Official Journal of the American science
the National Institutes of Health the
official monthly journal is August 1957
well the - trace minerals that you can
get to prevent and cure this are
chromium and vanadium vanadium alone
according to the University of Vancouver
British Columbia Medical School vanadium
alone will replace insulin in antal
onset diabetics which represent 85% of
all diabetics of course they can't quit
their insulin cold-turkey they got to
gradually wean off of it takes four to
six months for most people to slowly
wean off of insulin if they're taking in
adequate amounts of chromium and
vanadium now to me this is criminal
because if you write to hills packing
company that makes science dot dog for
the right over here in Topeka Kansas so
they manufacture signs diet dog food and
other signs diet product high tech foods
for animals if you write them and say
how many minerals exactly is in science
diet for dog food they'll write you back
and say there's 40 minerals you're right
checkerboard square in st. Louis Ralston
Koreans say just how many minerals are
in your rat pellets for laboratory rats
and they'll say there's 28 minerals
I'll give anybody in this room a crisp
new hundred-dollar bill if you can find
me a human infant formula and a grocery
store that has more than 11 so our dogs
get 40 minerals there's a Mike Murphy of
a sense dog never seems to get sick
because he's getting this canned dog
food with all these vitamins and
minerals
so our dogs get 40 minerals our rats get
28 minerals and our human infants get 11
is that fair
no that's called fraud doesn't matter if
you're talking about SMA Similac isome l
pro soy b fact that's why they call
Similac Similac because it lacks
everything okay if I've convinced you
that you have to consciously take in all
the minerals yourself that you can't
depend on your food and certainly can't
depend on anything that's boxed or
packaged or bottled there's three types
of minerals that you have to be
concerned about one is metallic minerals
and metallic minerals are essentially
ground up rocks metallic minerals are
things like oyster shell eggshell
dolomite limestone calcium carbonate
clays of various kinds mount marula
Knight clay sea bed minerals tums
they're only eight to 12 percent
absorbable when you reach age 35 to 40
it drops down to three to five percent
and I have to tell you a story here I
ran into a guy at a meeting like this up
at Grand Rapids Michigan and this fella
owns a port-a-potty business you know
that's that green or blue colored
outhouse man if we had only had one of
those back when I was a kid we had these
ones with splinters you know in the wood
he said I see something that describes
that my port-a-potty business I said
what's that
he says when we take those things back
to the shop to clean him out with the
pressure hose he says we put a quarter
inch grid underneath him because kids
throw rocks and sticks and toys in there
and if we don't put a grid there it
blocks up the sewer system it cost us
thousands of dollars to fix it every
time we clean one of those out we find
hundreds of vitamin tablets and said
well how do you know they're vitamin
tablets he said well that's really easy
he says right on the coating it says
teragrams m1a de Centrum
he says come here and he takes me on the
back of the shot and there's his literal
mountain of all these vitamin pills he
got out of his porta potties if you read
the labels on those multiples they say
your iron that comes in the form of iron
oxide what is iron oxide rust you might
as well just go out to an old railroad
track and take your butter knife and
scrape some of that rust off and lick it
and you're gonna get your iron
supplement that's what there
I'll show you how bad it is if you take
something like calcium lactate which is
a common metallic mineral let's say it's
a calcium tab of calcium lactate a
thousand milligrams if you take two of
those you're not getting 2,000
milligrams of calcium in fact I have
people all the time say well I took lots
of calcium doctor I hear you on the
radio talking about calcium and
arthritis and I took 2,000 milligrams of
calcium a day didn't help my arthritis
in fact it got worse as to what kind of
calcium you taken is that calcium
lactate well there's your problem
because only 250 milligrams of that is
metallic calcium so let's say absorb 10%
of that then the other 750 milligrams is
lactose or milk sugar so 10% of 250 is
25 so if you take two of those tablets
you're not getting 2,000 you're getting
50 milligrams so to get what you need
you need to take 90 of those tablets a
day you need to take 30 with each meal
and you got 59 more minerals to go then
there's those people who want to do
things naturally let's see if you can do
anything good with 10 pounds of spinach
and let's be fair let's see if you get a
thousand milligrams of magnesium and I
pick magnesium because in green leafy
vegetables you have a lot of magnesium
because of the chlorophyll rights part
of the chlorophyll molecule and any
pound of anything you got 454 grams and
10 pounds of spinach you got 4500 and 40
grams of which most of that 97% is water
let's say have one gram of chlorophyll
in that 10 pounds of spinach there's 50
milligrams of magnesium you got to
divide that into the thousand you want
you get a factor of 20 which you
multiply times the 10 you have to eat
200 pounds of spinach you got 58 more
minerals to go okay so you got to be a
pretty big person to accomplish all this
even as big as I am you can't get it
done so I preferred a supplemental
rather than do those things then of
course during the 60s the agricultural
industry came up with chelated minerals
because farmers aren't dumb enough to
pay for a dollar if something goes into
an animal's mouth and have 99 cents come
out in the manure I have to really thank
farmers for being that clever and
chelated minerals are just metallic
minerals with an amino acid or protein
or enzyme
wrapped around the metal atom and
increase the absorbability to 40% then
the health food industry jumped on that
right away because it was a major
improvement absorbability of minerals
the most efficient way to absorb
minerals is liquid they're very small
particle size are seven thousand times
smaller than a red blood cell and their
negatively charged so you actually have
an electrical or magnetic gradient that
concentrates these minerals plants have
a very interesting part to play in
colloidal minerals remember we said that
plants cannot create minerals they're
not in the soil plants can't make them
any rate metallic minerals are taken up
by plants when they're in the soil
plants convert them in their tissues to
colloidal minerals and this is how we
store minerals in our body this is how
we use minerals in our body this is how
we transport minerals from the storage
place to their site of use in the
colloidal farm
well our plants our crops don't have
much in the way of colloidal minerals in
them because we don't have any metallic
minerals in our soil there are these
minerals important you bet your life
they're important information and
statements regarding dietary supplements
discussed have not been evaluated by the
Food and Drug Administration and are not
intended to diagnose treat cure or
prevent any disease for more information
get back with the person who gave you